what's going on master Vontae I see
Andre Hopkins I'm Christian McCaffrey
mouth Sanders hi my name is Pat McAfee
I'm Terry Jackson no plant prospect I
made up jazz is a sensual sounding music
and it's also definitely a prospect in
this year's NFL Draft
I was a pretty realistic statistics
his name's jazz which could be made up
that's that's the prospect you say jazz
the prospect
okay there you go I could start off on
the wrong foot yeah that's what I'm
talking about jazz let's go
yeah he was in our ears in our group to
edit combine made up I said no I don't
see pepper having a snake let me say
made up here's you know why it's made up
no no no my when I was on a visual hell
okay okay house making sure I know about
that one
CrossFit okay you automatically have to
question people that have pet snakes
anybody that has a pet that doesn't have
a heart you got to wonder about that
thing is not laying and cuddling with
you
just thinking about killing you pepper
pepper Redmond is definitely prospered
would have been a good guy to draft
though I'm gonna say made up that's they
got to be like violating some being on
TV show that's made up made up made up
but they can't pay us we can't do shows
in NC a fun fact about jeté us Ortega
jr. to tape us or take a senior and I
had a night down in Miami he's doing
ballers he's gonna be in the NFL a man
his dad go way back this guy's a
prospect prospect yeah Malone University
isn't a real University this is made up
I'm gonna go ahead and say that's made
up made up
[Music]
Malone shot down in the GLIAC
shut up Malone University by the way
trying to come to a show by their made
up this is my guy Hunter hunter info
that's made up on those and that is made
up too easy if there's a molecular
physicist coming into the NFL that's
good for the shield
I think Mikey is a guy that's definitely
a prospect good old Mikey Austin Myers
bringing up the IQ of the NFL coming to
a league near you I knew that a white
guy molecular physicist no way
[Music]
made up made out that's made up the
highest pensions like 27 this is a
prospect for sure well anytime for you
to acknowledge by Ray Lewis that's
goodness I do know this guy cuz his
story went pretty large and I'm pulling
for a little Jordan to have a lot of
success in the NFL
he's prostrate CrossFit prospect you
save prostrate
I almost what's his name little what
this is the thing about right well I
know this guy they said he hit you so
hard put you to sleep they call nyquil
Reich well this dude is absolutely a
prospect not well he is a prospect
because I played him
oh we play temple this year so he's that
either really good player that's made up
here the second fastest
be honest some say made-up I don't know
Washington State I haven't really
watched a lot of run back so I usually
watch them they throw the ball a lot I
watched a lot of pac-12 ball I know max
Bowie one of the running backs
Washington State I don't they had a
couple but I'm gonna say that's made up
I'm gonna say this is a prospect for
sure those big-ass hands are gonna be
holding the football on Sundays Mondays
Thursdays in America Mexico Canada
London China wherever else they play an
NFL game shoutout to Trayvon for having
those good earrings as well
[Music]
that's prospect prospect for sure be
bawling oh my god that's my guy now yeah
that real I guess that's the game
it's a prospect if any snow junior dip
damn thing to Big Blue Nation down there
he's about to bring the wrath of hell
smell to wherever he had students
[Music]
I'm plating it that's made up so this
might be the one to get no hey I know I
just that's where you couldn't see too
many times on the class throw up the
rock hello Gavin at London mate Davis
Chester very much a British name not a
lot of winning since 1776 over there but
I think Davis Chester's gonna do a lot
of women with his next NFL team because
he's definitely a prospect this games
the worst scan is a tough game